I would love to hear tips for moving to
wake up earlier alarms and not
disturbing your spouse keep an alert
throughout the day you know when you
wake up earlier these are yeah is the
thing so tips for managing the
implications around making that change
to get up earlier while keeping the
space or that's keeping the speed or
keeping the peace at home and work you
put that work yet so uh either made a
typo or he's he's on the inside yeah
what that is not is that's a homage to
the Portuguese accent yes well no it's
it's a homage to the fake Portuguese
accent no it's the real one worki
yeah well anything adding like II like
it'll come out oh yeah yeah it could be
exaggerated though by certain people
myself included yeah okay so so how to
wake up in the morning number one let's
let's talk about one important piece
this how do you do it without disturbing
the spouse because we don't want to we
don't want to make the spouse angry no
adversarial relationships with this
phone at 4:30 no not at 4:30 so one of
the things real real easy one out of the
gate get an escalating alarm and so what
that means is it starts off quiet sure
and he gets louder it gets progressively
louder I am a much lighter sleeper than
my wife so this is not that big of a
deal to me and I can't answer but I've
I've slept with the roommates that
wanted to sleep you know like in the
military you know you got you got bunk
together or whatever so I've dealt with
this a little bit but it's really no
factor get an escalating alarm and then
when that thing goes off you you wake up
before it gets too loud to wake your
spouse it should be on your side of the
bed so you can make it happen or you can
pick a song that starts off nice and
mellow and that kind of builds and for a
long time for this particular reason I
used to have there's a band called the
sword sure is long and they have a song
called iron swan and it starts off nice
and mellow mmm if you don't get up in
time it's coming so you got it
so it's like a kind of like a game
within the game right there
where you gotta beat the clock yes yeah
you gotta beat the clock you've got to
get up and turn that thing because
otherwise it's an ant ant and then
you're too late
what is it Black Swan no iron Swan irons
what's the source yeah cuz there's
there's times in my life where I will
put like the ultimate shocker of a tune
in my in my playlist that if I need to
get up and I need to get up and get on
it like there's a song called repeat
repeat process by 100 demons that song
will get you out of bed he will get you
out of bed when it kicks in it just
comes it comes it's like it's like
forgetting it's it's like an explosion
happens in your room and it's a great
song by a great band but anyways so if
but in this case you don't want to go
with 100 demons no you don't want to go
with repeat process you want to go with
the sword iron song or an escalating
alarm now once you do that you've got to
have the gear pre-staged the gear has
the morning gear has to be pre-staged so
okay so we're not in a dressing we're
not pulling open drawers I'm not
flipping on lights or not searching for
stuff no we get up we walk out of the
room yeah quietly stealth mode then you
get to either the bathroom now if you
have the bathroom ensuite maybe you have
some stuff staged in the other bathroom
in the house so you just walk right out
of the room shut the door and you're
good you made your escape you know you
know oh and I'll tell you another thing
little heads up make sure that you set
off your secondary I mean that you turn
off your secondary and your tertiary
alarms so if you're like me and you
sleep with multiple alarm clocks
if you leave because they go off
sequentially right you know you got your
first one
iPhone then you got your second one
battery-powered then you get your third
one wind up the wind up is the gnarly
last one with the bra right right if you
leave that thing if you forget to shut
that thing off before you walk out you
didn't hear about it you
you can hear right because now when it
goes off it's a startled er because it
doesn't go off I mean most of the you
know 50% of time I'm up before the
alarms but but if you leave that one on
there it's a start alert and then then
your spouse is waking up in a panic mode
because now they don't know where it is
there's effort they're being attacked
it's it's a gnarly situation so shut off
the secondary and tertiary alarms and
then get out of the room and then you
know maybe even have your toothbrush and
your toothpaste staged and another in
the another bathroom or in the kitchen
or whatever got your workout gears not
in a drawer by the bed where you're
pulling that open making that racket no
you just get up and you leave so then
that's that's how you do it that's how I
do it and again I have an advantage
because my wife is a pretty heavy
sleeper mm-hmm she gets mad but when I
come home from a trip and late at night
I do some unpacking in the night that
can be a little frustrating for her but
anyways that's what she do now the next
piece of this question was for alertness
throughout the day what do you do to
stay alert throughout the day I think
one of the things you do is check your
diet right check the diet make sure in
my opinion make sure you're not
ingesting a tonne of carbohydrates
because those are gonna make you tired
they're gonna make you excited or make
you fire it up for about 20 minutes
I don't know haven't had them in a long
time for like 20 minutes before you eat
them
like great when you actually that's
really what they're for yeah you're
currently instant energy yeah yes well
and they put you to sleep so when you
when you eat it it's basically a really
basic sequence is I'm gonna do some
output you know in the wild I'm gonna go
hunting I'm not whatever you know I'm
gonna gather whatever do some output
that expended some energy I'm gonna need
some energy and I'm gonna need some rest
when you get the energy carbohydrates
food in anyway serotonin all these other
chemicals that induce you to go rest
that's the sequence that's the process
don't forget about insulin
yeah cuz he also put away there yeah the
insulin is gonna make you tired too so
check your diet
check your Diane I just had a guy on
Twitter man he's like hey man I'm tired
during the day I'm draggin I'm sick
we'll check your diet and he's like well
I think it's ok I'm drinking a lot of
energy drinks no not good the energy
drinks are addictive you know they're
tasty they're addictive and they're
they're filled with sugar most of the
time so you're gonna get a major sugar
rush and then you're gonna crash so you
got to be careful that also you don't
want to be on on the crazy amount of
caffeine all day and that's gonna mess
up your system as well does the same
thing is the sugar the caffeine rush and
then the crash that's that's the same
thing ok oh yeah more than sugar yeah in
in well I'll tell you right now people
ask me all the time they're surprised
that I work out without caffeine in the
morning but I'm telling you give it a
try yeah because it'll be harder and
maybe it's harder for you to get out of
bed maybe it's harder for you to get
ready maybe it's harder for you to get
into the gym with no caffeine and maybe
it's harder for you to start your
workout with no caffeine but once you
start the workout yeah I don't think
it's gonna be that big of a deal yeah
and if it is good make your workout
harder you know I don't think it's that
big of a deal so don't become addicted
to the caffeine and that's gonna be
because that can get problematic and
then power nap talked about this before
if you need to you take a little power
nap you take six to eight minutes you
set your alarm clock you velvet your
feet above your heart you lay down and
you can black out if you're really tired
you six to eight minutes of your feel
like you feel like a rock star after one
of those you know in another thing you
can do if you're tired during the day no
big deal
just find a little corner somewhere go
bang some push-ups out go bang out oh
ten burpees yeah yeah get the blood
flowing like the blood flowing yeah
there's no way it's it's it's
physiologically impossible to do burpees
and and remain tired whatever burpees
you can tell you you you bit since you
turned into a physiology major over here
and tonight if you want to tell me what
that does physiologically I don't know
but I do know this if you knock out ten
burpees this small small prescription
you will not be tired of for at least a
half an hour you're not gonna be 10
burpees and then feel fired
you can't do it I can tell you laughs
physiologically endorphins get released
there's stuff adrenaline like when you
know you're gonna do physical activity
when you know it you have it I'm not
saying a huge adrenaline just a little
bit yeah a little bit part of it
so that's those are some tips I guess
for alertness throughout the day that I
use and by the way go to bed earlier at
night yeah go to bed earlier tonight I
go to bed like I'm usually around 11 I
don't recommend that I don't recommend
going to bed at 11 and getting up at
4:30 no I don't recommend that I
recommend going to bed when you get
tired shut your computer off the stop
looking at the interwebs you know and go
to sleep
you know what go read an actual book
because that make you tired
you know that won't make you time that's
like the opposite of burpees go read go
meet a book you know and just sit there
and you will get more tired yeah unless
like a real exciting or interesting book
then well of course of course you don't
read but and you're cuz you're a fast
sleeper faster or you need that much
sleep but yeah yeah yeah the no sleep
thing that'll get you so quick it'll
promptly
put you into a crash the next day yeah I
don't know you can power well I don't
know I if I can go the neck even when
you had the latest little baby yeah you
came in here on a couple hours sleep
yeah you look rolled in here ready to
record you sat here you got after it
yeah it's true and there's all these
different doesn't it make you guys yeah
it makes you realize how much more you
can do I think a lot of people have like
this I don't want to go into this full
subject right now but the other day I
did a 72 hour fast right no food for 72
hours and there's a bunch of reasons we
could talk
maybe we'll do it on a later podcast I
will say this though what one small
thing if you go 72 hours without eating
it recalibrates your hunger meter
because we just think oh I haven't had
of a doughnut in two hours I'm starving
but no you're not starving yeah you're
not even hungry now I'm close to hungry
so recalibrate that thing do a fast even
if you just don't eat for 24 hours you
realize that most of your hunger signals
that are coming to your brain are lies
yeah and I'm not saying they're lies
like oh don't eat but I'm saying you
don't need to eat and how liberating is
it that I was having so much fun I was
on this fast and I'm just like don't
even need food I don't need I don't need
to eat that that's the ultimate control
right what I don't need food food is the
foods for food as if you're weak
you know maybe it's that type of you get
that mentality going and then guess what
now you go on a travel day and you go oh
man
I'm gonna be in the airport all day
today and I don't know what I'm gonna
don't want to eat anything you're
capable you're you know that you can go
72 hours as a matter of fact you can go
like 30 days without food
so going three days is not that big of a
deal it's not even that big of a deal
yeah I did when I just did this 72 hour
fast it was just not like I did
everything normal with jujitsu ever I
did worked out I did squats I did
pull-ups everything was normal
mm-hmm everything was almost not that
big crazy deal just we just get so
accustomed to to just feed in the
Machine all the time and you could have
a you know you gotta have a mini meal
every six hours and it's so at our
fingertips it's so but it's also you
this is what I realize it's so
inconvenient to have to eat all oh man
you know that's whack right so it's kind
of nice to just eat I know once a day
guess I put a big old steak on and get
after it
yeah I mean and again hey there's all
kinds of people and there's people that
know this isn't one of the reasons I
don't like talking about this particular
topic is because there's a lot of people
that like study this and know much about
this and up all these facts so me if I
go and do the research well I know the
facts too but I don't I can't my
consider and quote them right I don't
have the in-depth now
that Peter Atia has on fasting you know
anaemia or Dom D'Agostino those guys
there pH they're doctors
I'm not a doctor yeah I'm a knucklehead
that was and another things people you
know what did you do to prepare for your
faster I was like I didn't eat yeah I
was I was with Leif and we were on a
trip and we had like a lunch and then we
did a gig that night and I don't like to
eat before I do a gig and then after
that we stayed up a little bit and did
some work and then woke up the morning
at an early flight and then they came
home when I wanted to train so I worked
out and I got done with that and I went
and did something else and next thing I
knew its 24 hours my god you know what
the next day I feel too hungry so I just
held on so it wasn't no preparation just
got after it again people don't do this
anecdotal check with a physician or
whatever you gotta do don't listen to me
yeah as far as like a recommendation you
should do because you know you are
different and 70-hour fast okay I dig it
man but I think really kind of the point
that you're making or one of them anyway
I think is absolutely true so you're you
know a lot of it is like habitual hunger
but it goes beyond just like
psychological have [ __ ] it's like
physiological it's like okay I'm used to
getting food every four hours so when
the four hour mark comes around
physiologically your stomach's gonna be
like where my food yeah your mouth where
my food and then after a while if you're
like hey you don't get food this time
you're something here okay sometimes we
don't get food yeah so let's kind of act
right you know and then when the food
comes okay we'll do that when that habit
recalibration is real though because
then after I started eating again and
then the next day I go um I'm feeling
hungry I'm gonna eat something I know
I'm actually not hungry so why am i
eating why am i eating if I'm not hungry
mmm yeah that's my mind is controlling
me when I should be controlling my mind
yeah you know so and that's another
thing where um your your earth is
nothing new right your mind is so strong
or whatever so you can trick yourself
and this goes for sleep too so if you
think that you got nine hours of sleep
you'll be way less tired then okay let's
say two people exact people they're
identical twin right identical life
experience whatever one guy believes the
next morning okay they both got eight
hours sleep
one guy believes he only got four hours
sleep and one guy believes he got
nurse Lee typical possible scenario yeah
but that's how your mind it knows like
basically it's your mind accommodating
what it thinks the stimulus is so so the
other twin the four hours sleep believer
he's gonna be way more tired and he's
got dang where's that nap I was looking
forward I need whatever the other
imagine if you woke up every day and you
were like I only got four hours of
sleeping I'm gonna crushed it exactly
right I actually believe I work better
on less sleep how you like them apples
exactly exactly and that's right that's
was gonna be my point there where you're
like I told you I've told you that
before yeah after I've so I've told echo
before that when we're getting ready to
record the podcast the day before I
record the podcast that night I like to
sleep less like four hours because I
feel like it sharpens I'll tell you what
to be quite honest with it what I think
it does it it brings it it brings my
emotions a little closer to the surface
so like you feel like work I'm kind of
under attack so I better wait like I
better like pardon up right now I better
like get my that it's like no this is
what it is I can get more like when I'm
reading something I'm more focused on it
I'm more into it like actively yeah
because I think when I'm well-rested I'm
like a like a like rock solid right oh
yeah when I'm a little when I sleep less
I'm a little bit more exposed I'm a
little bit more vulnerable right
mentally right and I need that because
otherwise I just become very detached I
become very detached and it's it's you
know so I want it when I come in here I
want to be on though I want to be on the
fringe a little bit right right a man
that's I want to be exposed I want to be
walking in here me like man this is
gonna be this is an intense this ain't
not a walk in the park today no this is
gonna be hard to live in so I wanna yes
I want to be stressed a little bit when
I come in here yeah
and I didn't dig it and I feel I always
felt like a blanket the same thing in
jiu-jitsu I feel better when I'm
stressed and when I'm a little bit more
yeah a little bit more stressed a little
bit more tension a little bit more
pressure on myself I want to be there
yeah make it a lot of be the wrong time
and I'll tell you what just so everybody
knows there's some days where I'm tired
when I'm just tired and I just sometimes
I just need a power nap so bad I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm literally falling asleep
you know and I hate that that's a
horrible feeling but you know what
elevate your feet set our alarm clock
for eight minutes boom you're gonna wake
up feeling like Superman like when
people hit themselves before they go
lift because it weighed me they like
slapped them so much yeah for sure so
the surface looks like all he's getting
fired up but yeah why is he getting
fired up for the exact same reason that
you're talking about because if it's
like bomb like I'm getting these things
where I got to kind of bounce back home
right I'm under attack I got a little
bit adrenaline rush too right so
physiological it's the same exact
sequence right there but you're just
doing it consciously and instead of
slaps it's lack of sleep yes or what
have you there you go that's the answer
and everyone's going to attack me on
social media for not sleeping not eating
and all that I appreciate your advice I
know I should I dunno I should sleep or
I dunno I should eat you know better
I'm sorry what does that mean even
should the work should what does that
even mean you should it's yeah anyway
that's the whole eat chocolate don't be
you any more well it's great be
different than you that's what that well
actually actually the point out the what
I was gonna say earlier is just like hey
what you're saying the like you're not
citing all the science and making claims
about like well how this is gonna
benefit you or nothing like that that's
not what you're doing it's it is
anecdotal and I think the point is that
if you push yourself through certain
situations and you prove it to yourself
that you can function just fine with I
don't know five hours sleep rather than
eight one or two times or or whatever or
hammering
you know that you can do that like
really you know we'd talked about this
before where you get kind of dependent
on certain things and then to the point
where you believe that you can't
function without it
whether it be sleep whether it be coffee
in the morning you know whatever or
eating every four hours like when I was
really into like weightlifting and
bodybuilding type stuff I remember
thinking man I got a I got a hurry-up
Heat it's four hours or whatever and
then kind of later on in life man I've
got like I haven't eaten yet today and
it's late in the day mmm I'm fine you're
not but games game whatever yeah so once
you prove it to yourself it's like if
you stay up all night when you have work
the next day you do your work when you
go to bed you can be like hey if I had
to I could do that again
that is another thing that I enjoy about
pushing those envelopes is it feels
really good to go to bed when you've
been awake for a long time it feels
really good to eat a meal once you
haven't eaten for for a while you you
appreciate it yeah that's good that's
true but that's kind of a psycho way of
invoking appreciation okay my opinion
understood